so as he said a minute ago this is not a
surprise
the law and that matters because it's
the supreme court we're talking about
the law behind the roe v wade decision
of 1973 was so shoddy and ridiculous
because of course abortion's not
mentioned in the constitution not even
alluded to
that a lot of people figured out a long
time ago that it would at some point be
overturned because it was too absurd to
continue
and so a lot of states have been
preparing for more than a dozen of them
have what are called trigger laws that
will take effect now that roe v wade has
been overturned
and a lot of them will outlaw most
abortion so eventually roughly half the
country is expected to implement
significant new restrictions on abortion
and that matches public opinion polling
on abortion which is to say a lot of
people don't like abortion if you live
in new york city you might not know any
of them but if you live in mississippi
you know quite a few the point is people
will get to live with the laws they want
how's that bad
today the state of missouri became the
very first state to ban abortion the
state's attorney general is eric schmidt
and we're happy to have him join us
tonight mr general thanks so much for
coming on so what is the state of
abortion on missouri now
yeah missouri became the first state
after the decision the dobbs decision
day to effectively end abortion and this
is something that's been worked on for
decades people have preyed upon this
it's a long time coming thankfully
president trump appointed three
conservative justices that knew that the
road decision as justice alito said the
day it was issued was on a collision
course with the constitution and we see
that here today now and so this issue
will be decided as it should have been
49 years ago
to the states missouri interestingly in
1825 was the first state to formally
prohibit abortion that was the law of
our state until roe v wade and now we're
back to where it should have always been
and so it's a big day and i think as
you've pointed out it's a big day for
democracy for these for the voters now
to have a stay as opposed to nine
justice unelected justices back 49 years
ago that decided this for everybody in
the country and i think what you're
seeing now with this right night of rage
that's been talked about the justice
department has no interest in condemning
it they haven't done anything to stop it
you've seen an assassination attempt of
a supreme court justice
you see this intimidation that's going
to continue the justice department's way
more interested evidently in sicking the
fbi and going after parents who show up
to school board meetings under the
patriot act then arresting folks who are
intimidating
supreme court justices this is out of a
banana third world republic but
thankfully the rule of law
was
was a buttress today and missouri was
the first state to take action i was
proud to do that as the state's chief
legal officer
i'm glad this is back in the political
arena where it belongs where voters can
decide and and one effect is people are
going to have to start
affirmatively defending abortion and not
hiding behind these stupid slogans and
euphemisms oh it's choice it's a health
care procedure it's a human right really
what is it and why don't you tell us why
you're for it you look forward to that
conversation
absolutely and that's where it should
have been all along tucker and so here
we are now 49 years later with the reset
and the people get to weigh in it's what
was always intended as opposed to roe v
wade which was made out of a
constitutional right made out of whole
cloth
yeah it's amazing i mean
they hate democracy like the devil hates
holy water it is just amazing to see it
eric schmidt well it's about the state
of missouri
thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight